do you think it's hanging smoke I think
the shrimp welcome back to chef's out of
water I'm Alexis a chef who's always up
for a challenge we've asked you Internet
to decide what unconventional clients I
should cook a three-course meal I feel
really nervous but I'm ready to find out
what I've got worthless today air fryer
pretty good this feels like a win I have
actually used an air fryer before I have
a good foundation of how this works I
think I've gotta do a bit of research to
find out what exactly I'm gonna make and
I feel really excited this is gonna be
great so air fryers aren't that
complicated
there's basket so you can prop stuff up
on it the heat comes from the bottom and
kind of circulates it around there
pretty simple I mean I know that's
famous last words but previously I've
been a roast chicken I make chicken
wings how haenyeo poppers a bunch of
chips like vegetable chips that's pretty
easy someone's made cannoli before
people are really into shrimp coconut
shrimp fried shrimp you can make lobster
tails in an air fryer I've got my
grocery list I'm gonna have Ryan go out
and grab a few things
and in the meantime I'm gonna get
started on what we have in the pantry
confidence is a solid seven I feel fine
I feel fine I mean how poorly in the
scuffle okay so I'm gonna work backwards
and I'm gonna start with dessert I'm
gonna make a cherry cake tart torte
thing which is based off of New York
Times recipe which is super popular
foolproof I've made it in an oven so
many times it's never gone wrong so I
well I hope it works in there for higher
buttons we'll see first step is put it
on power great temp look at this and
then start I'm starting by creaming some
butter and some sugar if I was at home I
would use a mixer ooh
this butter is certainly not soft yet
maybe I'll put it in the airfryer to
melt it a bit for a second
this could be a terrible idea
no no no great idea
scraping it slightly melted look at that
Wow very efficient
well oh my god it's ready my best ideas
now I'm gonna add my egg
and it should make these like swoopy
ribbons and some baking powder to help
it rise pinch of salt just want to get
it all combined and I'm gonna fold in
some cherries using frozen cherries but
if you had fresh could use that too and
so I've got a little tiny tin buttered
it put some parchment down just gonna
add the cake little cake is going in see
you in 15 minutes
yeah it's a little work but also appears
to be a little wrong I don't know what
to do think I need to do this again okay
I've made another batter exactly the
same clean pan I'm going to do a lower
temperature this time I'm also gonna put
it on roast instead of airfryer and
cover it with think between those three
things it's roast my confidence awful
I'm gonna still say a seven you know I
think you got off to a rocky start but
something's gonna work well the cake is
baking I'm gonna get started on prepping
my next course ribs with corn pudding
I love ribs I didn't grow up with corn
pudding and have had it honestly like
twice in my life but it was really good
and it feels like it goes with ribs and
I feel like it's gonna work in here so
so I need my butter melted again but the
airfryer is occupied
ah I'm gonna take the cake out for a
minute I'm gonna put the butter into a
second it's gonna be fine
I'm just gonna check on the cake hold my
butters melting you know I think it just
needs more time needs more time still
fully raw just need some more time
okay my confidence is waning
[Music]
butter adding it the eggs to the butter
and add some cornstarch sugar some
jalapeno for some heat some salt fresh
corn this is cream corn it kind of looks
like baby food at this stage but it's
gonna get good but with some cheese it's
butter paper towel just gonna butter the
insides of these ramekins and I'm just
gonna fill them with the court a little
cheese on top okay my corn pudding is
ready to go cake looks like it's ready
also to go I mean we'll see 20 minutes
30 minutes okay moment of truth well it
just it you know it needs some more time
I think just for times sake I'm gonna
have Ryan finished cooking this off with
a second airfryer I'm gonna do one each
time so next up I'm going to do a no
cook barbecue sauce for my ribs
typically you simmer barbecue sauce to
get it really intensified with flavor
but that's not an option so I'm gonna
start with some ketchup and some brown
sugar some salt black pepper paprika and
a little garlic powder and then some
were chester shires us
we're chester sugar where's Chester sure
we're sure sure where sister sherry
sauce
so wash your shirt
if all those fails I've made some
barbecue sauce I've got all the same
ingredients for the dry rub so I'm just
gonna throw some of this together
salt pepper NATO brown sugar some Greek
some garlic powder mix it together look
at that oh my god two birds one stone
I'm just gonna wait for the corn pudding
put this aside we're moving right along
things are going I'm going back up to a
seven to one it's oh my god it's wow it
smells amazing it looks beautiful oh my
god
because I have two of these I'm gonna
save the second one and I'm just gonna
test this to make sure that it's fully
cooked inside it looks well it's not
cooked inside why is this not working
maybe it just needs to go for a longer
moving onto the ribs obviously this is
not gonna fit in an air fryer so I'm
gonna just divide it up a bit
take some of this and just rubbing it
over ribs are remind me of the Delaware
County Fair just reminds me of like
summer being a kid you've no cares in
the world are you gonna get another
ticket to go on the Scrambler that's all
you have to worry about not any more
kids
my ribs are ready to go so as soon as my
a second corn pudding comes out I'm
gonna pop the ribs in well we just found
out what's wrong with this which is I
forgot to my heavy cream in it so it's
not gonna set I'm gonna make another
batch of corn pudding I'm also going to
put them into smaller ramekins so that I
can do two at a time
it looks beautiful though so I think got
high hopes okay so I've got a fresh
batch of corn pudding I think the
smaller size is also gonna help them
cook faster and obviously if heavy cream
is gonna ensure that they actually said
[Music]
15 seconds I'm just gonna do it oh
they're like little corn souffles they
look amazing
still still raw
I honestly think it needs like five more
minutes and it's gonna go it's almost
there remember this morning when I was
like air fryer so easy yeah but they're
pretty simple I mean I know that's
famous last words it was a mistake I
made a mistake oh okay they look
beautiful
it's bouncy but it's brings back it's
not raw inside looks good I think I can
finally move through the corn pudding
Sokka I'm gonna move on to ribs
it's rib time my favorite time let's
start with these guys cool this is
smoking but
Oh oh my god they went insane like
insanely good not bad I think this is a
case where smoking is fine obviously if
it's billowing smoke I'd be more
concerned so Ryan finished off the cake
and let's take a look it's pretty
perfect okay moment of truth it's
actually so pretty
I mean it's tiny but it smells great it
looks so pretty really happy this worked
it was not looking good this morning I'm
gonna move on to my final course which
is actually the appetizer I'm gonna make
shrimp po-boy sliders first I'm going to
start with a remoulade which is
basically like a Mayo based sauce it's
got some relish some mustard some hot
sauce and some lemon
no you guys I'm really nailing the no
cook salsas and I'm going to make a like
spiced buttermilk mixture that the
shrimp can just like hang out in for a
bit some buttermilk then pepper I've got
some paprika ooh
I've paprika and cayenne I think this is
Cayenne
[Music]
yep
holy
okay great
so we've got some paprika it's tiny bit
of cayenne the tip of my tongue is on
fire and some dried thyme oh my god it's
really spicy it's really really basic it
a good stir
adding the shrimp and then just let it
get covered like that Wow whew she's
gonna just get in crispy got my no cook
barbecue sauce backside to the ribs have
been basted back in well that's going
I'm just gonna make my quick flour
cornmeal batter for the shrimp really
just eyeballing this flood of love salt
but because the shrimp are soaking in
the buttermilk it's gonna make sure that
the cornmeal and flour actually infuse
to it so you get that crust I actually
feel really good about the shroom I know
he keeps a hundred it fails but I
legitimately think the shrimp are gonna
be easy and like cooking no time okay
the ribs look great
they're virgin on blackened but don't
grate I think I'm just need to cut one
to test
there's not bad little salty which I
personally like but that's fine that's
totally fine I feel really good about
this I think we can move on to the
shrimp I'm going to dip my buttermilk
shrimp into the cornmeal put it on here
right up it sounds like it's frying it's
like
that was a decision person Haitian few
things ready it is Rob's no it looks
disgusting so I think I need to try it
for five minutes maybe higher heat to
this is not my mail this is not my meal
one for this level is like that for like
a five that's a five you guys I think
the shrimp have betrayed me this looks
really bad
so should be it's cooked okay I'm gonna
pivot scratch the po-boy gonna rinse
these off I'm gonna put a little dry rub
on it it's just gonna be a little spicy
shrimp slider it's got some salt got
some pepper that's a pretty good they
need any bit of cayenne
mix it up pour out my shrimp is one trip
time again I really really really want
this to work I've had to redo every
single thing today like multiple times
ah it's so salty it's kind of good but
like guys I'm so sorry I am I'm gonna
wash the shrimp off again
andrey spiced them but I know the cook
time so it's gonna go really smoothly
this time it's seasoned properly now so
I'm gonna do a bunch of shrimp at once
knock it out I know how much to do start
got all my slider not po-boy slider
ingredients ready to go
shrimp is about to come out
beautiful oh I'm gonna put some
Remillard on both sides a very big
tomato and then two shrimp nice slider
done
OOP my sliders are ready to go I'm gonna
finish plating up my entree I've got the
ribs the corn pudding gonna top it with
some scallions and lastly I have the
cherry torte
I'm gonna just dust some powdered sugar
on it before serving and then it's taste
tester time we made it
nope this is my friend Michi I'm Nicci
and she's gonna taste test my
three-course mates and I am so excited
okay
first course we've got spiced shrimp
sliders Wow
I love anything in Sandwich forms that's
amazing though holy crap
that is such a juicy piece of shrimp in
there yeah I love that oh my goodness
okay course number two yes we've got
ribs and no I don't think I have I've
had it like twice so I'm not angry at
that at all actually I kind of like it
yeah yeah it almost reminds me of like a
macaroni and cheese texture with like
you know this meat here the like roots
you can totally totally just go straight
in there they're not like salsa bones
but the key to a good ribs is a
delicious flavor and that's got
delicious flavor
that might be one of the best ribs that
I've had like in a while you're kind of
killing it oh my god okay so for dessert
we've got a cherry tart okay I'm sure
your cake okay I don't like cherry this
is really good yeah it's really
surprising when you get the actual fruit
in there it's a very nice light
refreshing you know I really love this
Alexis you are the bomb.com oh my god
the most important question yes what do
you think I made this was I can't
believe all of those came from one
device I feel like it has to be
something that's actually meant to be
cooked to it I feel like you have to
have how
some kind of oven like a toaster oven
let's say it's toaster oven great guest
ok all three of these were made in an
air fryer ok
yeah that makes sense that makes sense
you did freaking awesome this is amazing
thank you for having me I'm gonna go
ahead and say that you know I look like
I said it's a little sandwich situations
my favorite I appreciate you guys thank
you so much for feeding me I'll see you
later you know it's been a it's been a
really long day and this was really hard
for me neech you've really made it
better she'll make me feel good about
things I need to take this newfound
confidence with meat cheese praise and
take it into the next few days
[Music]
you